he he weaponized the irs with billions
of dollars and he also put a minimum
corporate tax of 15 percent and the
money is staggering joining us right now
victor davis hanson hoover institute
senior fellow victor is he right there's
no new taxes in this
no he's wrong you're right there's new
taxes there's new regulations there's an
exp a spanish expansion of government
somehow we're in a rock and a hard place
we're in classical stagflation we have
nine one nine point one percent annual
inflation
and we have two quarters of negative
growth and you got to pick your poison
brian ronald reagan broke it and he was
very unpopular in 81 and 82 very
courageous but he broke inflation so the
interest rates to break inflation have
got to go up spending has to go down
and you've got to deregulate and
encourage the economy but when you do
that and interest rates go up we could
get two three four five six quarters of
negative growth and so we we we brought
back stagflation that a whole generation
hadn't witnessed or two generations
since 1980 in the quarter years they
keep pointing to this 3.6 unemployment
rate they said no no don't use the
recession word but that's that's also
misleading because there's a lag behind
employment and recession by that i mean
consumer confidence is down people are
buying less
employers are pulling in their
expansionary plans and we're going to
see a dip
in the uh we're going to see a rise in
unemployment but more importantly
the is a labor uh participation rate we
have a lot of people that are not
participating because they got
acculturated to stay home during the
covet lockdowns they were subsidized by
the government with these massive last
year of the of the trump administration
but especially the biden administration
these trillions of dollars that we
spread and gave checks to people a lot
of people are afraid of covet they're
they're they're locked down we had a lot
of premature retirements people who were
63 4 or 5 just said i'm out of here
we had people who did not participate
because they did not want to get
vaccinated in the military and federal
workforce they were afraid of mandates
we have people
who have long coveted maybe 10 million
of them have not recovered so
i don't see any optimism on the one the
one area where they were very optimistic
they said we're not in recession because
we have 3.6 unemployment i think it's
going to rise very quickly and the
people there they're not participating
so it's a misleading figure to begin
with and it's going to explain why we're
not having very much growth
so
and i'm also getting arguing about how
they did it but they've managed to go in
less than a year and a half to take a
very solid recovering economy with
natural demand that was going to accrue
after the lockdown
and regulate it and tax it and uh
inflate it to death and
we're in a really bad place so pick your
poison you either yeah speak to a
recession or stop validation but
uh it's and while letting four million
people illegally into the country we
know nothing about uh and so i think the
most egregious is the name inflation
reduction act inflation reduction
actually should be the climate change
act uh with some fossil fuel provisions
victor davis hanson thanks so much hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else